- Hi, everyone. My name's Daniel Botsman.
I teach Japanese history here at Yale,
and it is an incredible privilege today
to be able to welcome to
campus Ms. Toshiko Tanaka
and her daughter, Ms. Reiko Tashiro.
In addition to thanking
them both for being here
and for making the long,
exhausting journey from
Japan to the East Coast,
I do also want to
express my deep gratitude
to Anthony Shimamoto from
the University of Connecticut
School of Law, and Takeshi
Watanabe from Wesleyan University
for arranging their visit and opening up
this extraordinary opportunity
to us here at Yale.
As I'm sure you all know,
Tanaka-san brings today
a message of the greatest importance,
one that is hard to
believe anyone in the world
after 1945 could ever forget.
And yet, according to the
Bulletin of the Atomic Scientists,
we now live in a time
of unprecedented danger
with the so-called Doomsday Clock set
at just 90 seconds to midnight,
the closest we've ever
been, in other words,
to true global catastrophe.
And of course, all over the world,
we've seen the continued
proliferation of nuclear weapons.
As those of you who attended
last week's John W. Hall lecture
by the eminent political scientist,
Richard Samuels from MIT
know, today, even in Japan,
the only country in the world
to have experienced the
horrors of a nuclear attack,
politicians are openly
discussing the acquisition
of nuclear weapons in order, they say,
to counter the threats
of North Korea and China.
Here at Yale, I'm glad to say
that there have been those
over the years who have written
and spoken about the horrors
that befell the people of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki in August, 1945.
To give just two prominent
examples, John Hersey,
who served as head of Pierson
College from 1965 to 1970
and taught writing here
for almost 18 years
may have done more than any other American
to make ordinary people
in this country aware
of the horrors of the nuclear bombings
with his landmark 1946 essay, "Hiroshima."
50 years later in 1996, John
Treat, only recently retired
from the East Asian Languages
and Literatures Department
published his important
book, "Writing Ground Zero:
Japanese Literature and the Atomic Bomb."
It's so important that we have
access to works like these
that describe on the page what happened,
but it's one thing to be able
to read about the horror.
It is quite another to
be able to hear directly
from someone who lived through it.
In this regard, I can only say again
what a truly special
privilege it is for us
to have Tanaka Toshiko-san
here with us today.
Please join with me now in extending her
the very warmest possible welcome.
(audience applauding)
(Reiko Tashiro speaks in Japanese)
- First of all, my mother
and I would really thank you
for having us here today.
We would especially like to
extend our sincere gratitude
to the people and organizations
who made this event possible.
My name is Reiko Tashiro. I'm from Japan.
I'm a second-generation
hibakusha or a A-bomb survivor.
Since I was a child, I have
believed that nuclear weapons
cannot coexist with humanity.
My mother once told me
that when I was born,
the first thing my father had
to do was count my fingers
and toes to make sure that
I had no birth defect.
In those days, even though
people survived themselves,
they had to worry about radiation
damage to their children.
Today, I would first give a
brief overview of the damage
caused by the atomic bomb on Hiroshima.
Then my mother, Toshiko,
will tell you her story,
and we will have a question
and answer session afterward.
During the talk, we would like
to share some of the photos
of Toshiko's enamel mural works,
which she has created for over 50 years,
putting her wishes for peace.
We would like to give you a prior warning.
Some of the pictures
and stories being shared
might cause some of you
discomfort and you might decide
whether you would prefer to avoid them.
Oops, yes.
It's not skipped. Yes.
- On August 6th, 1945 at 8:15
AM the atomic bomb was dropped
targeting a bridge at the
center of Hiroshima city.
The bomb exploded 2,000
feet above the ground,
releasing intense heat,
blast, and radiation.
Near the hypocenter, the blast is believed
to have had a speed of
about 1,000 feet per second.
Buildings which were mostly
made of wood at the time
collapsed over a wide area.
People were blown away
by the tremendous blast.
At the moment of explosion,
the temperature near the center
was believed to be between
5,400 and 7,200 Fahrenheit.
This is a picture of stone
steps at the entrance of a bank.
The intense heat turned
the steps whiteish,
and the stone under the
person sitting there
waiting for the bank
to open remained dark.
This tricycle belonged
to a three-year-old boy,
Shinichi Tetsutani, who died in the attack
while he was playing on his
favorite toy, his tricycle.
Considering the iron
melts at 2,700 Fahrenheit,
people's skin who were
outside near the hypocenter
must have been charcoaled instantly.
The atomic bomb differs from other bombs
because it emits radiation,
which causes cellular and
genetic abnormalities.
The vast majority of
people exposed to radiation
within 0.6 miles died even
if they were unharmed.
Also, many people are believed
to be damaged by exposure
to residual radiation from the fallout,
so-called deadly ash,
and rain mixed with radioactive materials,
so-called black rain.
Radiation can cause
various long-term diseases
such as leukemia, thyroid cancer,
breast cancer, and colorectal cancer.
Even now, it's affecting many people.
Although the exact
number is still unknown,
140,000 people in Hiroshima
and over 70,000 people in Nagasaki
are estimated have died
by the end of the year.
On July, 2017, a global
agreement to ban nuclear weapons
known as the Treaty on the
Prohibition of Nuclear Weapons
or TPNW was adopted at the United Nations,
which entered into force
on January 22nd, 2021.
Before the treaty's adoption,
nuclear weapons were the only
weapons of mass destruction
not subject to a comprehensive ban
despite their humanitarian and
environmental consequences.
It prohibits nations from
developing, testing, producing,
manufacturing, transferring,
processing, stockpiling, using,
or threatening to use nuclear weapons
or allowing nuclear weapons
to be stationed on their territory.
It also prohibits them from
assisting, encouraging,
or inducing anyone to engage
in any of these activities.
The Nobel Peace Prize 2017 was awarded
to the International Campaign
to Abolish Nuclear Weapons
or ICAN for its work to draw attention
to the catastrophic humanitarian
consequences of any use
of nuclear weapons or for
its groundbreaking efforts
to achieve a treaty-based
prohibition of such weapons.
There are now 13,000 nuclear
warheads in the world,
which is enough to wipe out
every living thing on the planet
multiple times over.
More than 90% of them belong
to the United States and Russia.
My mother and I are here to speak to you
not because we want to make
you feel guilty or sorry,
but because we hope that
we can work together
to create a more peaceful world.
The average age of hibakusha in Hiroshima
is now over 84 years old.
My mother is also 84.
In the near future,
we will not be able to
hear directly from them
so let's invite Toshiko
to share her story.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
(Reiko Tashiro speaks Japanese)
- Hello, my name is Toshiko Tanaka.
I survived the atomic
bombing in Hiroshima.
Hibakusha is how we call all
the survivors in Japanese.
I've been creating enamel mural
artwork for over 50 years.
It wasn't easy for me to talk about,
but I'm going to tell you today.
I tried not to remember what had happened
in Hiroshima on August the 6th, 1945.
I thought people would not understand me.
I would not ever talk to anybody
about my personal experience
of the atomic bombing,
not even to my own family.
I started to open up
and share this horrible,
this experience when I turned 70.
It is a miracle for me
to be able to tell you my story today.
Hopefully we are all here
to stop something like this
from ever happening again.
Originally, my family
lived only 500 meters,
540 yards from ground
zero where the bomb hit.
But just one week before
the atomic bombing,
we moved 2.3 kilometers away,
1.4 miles away from ground zero.
Because of this, I am alive today,
even though I was burned
and exposed to radiation.
When I was just six years old,
the gigantic mushroom
cloud was right above me.
At 8:15 AM, I was on my way to school.
Somebody shouted. (speaks Japanese)
I looked up and saw a tremendous flash.
It was like a million lights.
Everything went white. I couldn't see.
I covered my face with my right arm.
Heat burned my head, my
neck, and my right arm.
Then suddenly everything
went dark, like nighttime.
Hot sand dust blew up. It covered the Sun.
I couldn't see, but the dust cloud
was like a giant mushroom.
My mouth was full of dust.
What was happening? What should I do?
I can't forget that
terrible crunchy sand taste.
Soon my burns began to swell.
The pain was incredible.
I cried all the way home,
but our household very
damaged when I got there.
Even though my mother was alive,
she could not recognize me.
My hair was burned. I was covered in ash.
My clothes were destroyed.
That night, I was close to death.
Many doctors were dead.
There were no hospitals left.
Survival depended on how
strong you were and how lucky.
My younger sister had bad head wounds.
My father was away in the army.
Our roof was mostly gone,
but suddenly I looked up and
saw a small patch of blue sky.
Although I was in pain, I
thought, "This is so beautiful."
That blue sky stayed with me.
It had given me the will to
live as if the heavens said,
"Don't worry, there will be a tomorrow."
This is why I continued
to live life positively,
even through many hardships.
(claps sharply) It took only
one second for a single bomb
to the destroy the city of
Hiroshima and 140,000 lives
and another bomb to kill
70,000 more in Nagasaki.
All my classmates were killed.
My younger aunt left home that
morning and never came back.
Her body was never found.
Every image of that terrible day remained.
My generation will be the last
to tell you about this event
as direct witnesses.
This is what I saw.
After I got home that day,
I saw a large crowd of dying people.
They were walking in
procession near my house.
Some were orphans.
Men, women, and children alike
were almost naked with burned clothes.
They walked in silence
with outstretched arms.
Burned peeled skin hung from
their tips of their fingers.
They were like ghosts.
Even today, whenever I
see barbecued tomatoes,
it reminds me of that
terrible scene of death.
Like tomatoes, human skin
peels off easily when burned.
I have another strong memory of that time.
I was unconscious for a few days.
When I woke up, there was
a strong smell in the air.
It was like burning rotten fish.
Even now I can still smell it,
but the smell wasn't the fish.
It was the smell of the
human bodies being cremated
in city parks and the school grounds.
Even though our family had nothing,
my mother sheltered many
people in our house.
One was her cousin, Kenzo Matsuki.
He came to our house with a burned bucket
containing the skull of a
woman he wishes to bury.
The skull belonged to his aunt.
His aunt was burned
alive in her own house.
People around her, not to do anything
because she was trapped
badly in the burning house.
They themselves had to escape from fire.
They begged for her forgiveness
while departing her.
I also remember a 15 old
girl who came to our house.
On her back, she carried her
badly burned younger sister.
The burned girl survived,
but the older girl did not.
She had been exposed to massive radiation.
My husband's uncle was an English teacher
and a devout Christian.
He used to paint beautiful
pictures and believed in peace,
but the bomb killed him
and all his six family
members, including his baby.
Grieving their loss, my husband adopted
his uncle's family name Tanaka.
My husband has now died, but
I still carry this last name.
In those days, the city of Hiroshima
and the surface of the rivers
which run through the city
were entirely covered by people's bodies.
There were also 12
young American prisoners
of war in Hiroshima.
They also died from the bomb
dropped by their own country.
Later, something weird started
to happen in Hiroshima.
People with no injuries started to die.
No one knew then,
but they had been exposed
to massive radiation.
Exactly how much radiation
the atomic bombs produced
is still unknown.
Do you know the famous story
of Sadako and her paper cranes?
Sadako was four years younger than me,
and we went to the same school.
She survived the atomic bomb
when she was two years old,
but died of leukemia at age 12.
There were many other
children like Sadako.
In my case, radiation symptoms
started when I was 12.
My white blood cell count was abnormal.
I suffered constant fever and
fatigue and sometimes fainted.
I always had mouth ulcers
and bruises around my mouth.
It was hard to eat.
Even today, when I am very tired,
I have painful sores and can't sleep.
I sometimes bleed from my colon.
I have had three ribs broken
and knee surgery and cataract surgery.
The Japanese government decided
to certify atomic bomb victims
only within two kilometers,
1.24 mile radius of ground zero.
Since I lived 300 meters,
328 yards beyond this radius
my symptoms are not officially certified
as atomic bomb related.
Some other victims have
tried to sue the government,
but instead I decided to
spend the rest of my life
on my art and testimony.
For more than six years
after the end of the war,
the American government
hid the radiation damage
by blocking the media.
In those days, the country
was competing against the USSR
in nuclear arms development
and wanted to carry out
numerous nuclear tests.
It was also developing
nuclear power generation
under the name of peace facilitation
so the damage caused by radioactivity
was uncomfortable truth
for the government.
So without knowing, citizens
drank contaminated water
and ate vegetables grown
in contaminated grounds.
Later, many relatives and
friends died from leukemia
and other forms of cancer.
Those days, hibakusha also
suffered discrimination
in Japanese society.
In those those days, hibakusha
women had trouble marrying
because their babies
often had birth defect.
Fortunately, I was able to marry
and had a happy family life.
My husband did not seem to
mind that I was a hibakusha,
but when our first child,
Reiko, was born, he was scared.
He seriously checked the
baby's fingers and toes.
Then I realized that he had been worried
about the damage of the bomb on our baby.
Not just my husband,
but all parents those days were worried.
Up until now, there still
had not been enough research
on the impact of radioactivity
on the second generation.
No doctors can give any
legitimate diagnosis.
There is no proof that
the second generation
can maintain their health.
The hibakusha continue to
feel sorry for their children
and have to carry this
psychological burden
for their entire life.
Before the bomb, our family line
generally had been
blessed with good health.
However, after the bomb,
three of my sister's daughters
who are second-generation hibakusha
were afflicted with thyroid disease.
One of them had surgery
to remove thyroid cancer
at the age of 22.
My younger brother,
who is also a second-generation hibakusha
had surgery to remove colon cancer
when he was still quite young.
Doctors say there is no evidence
to connect these diseases
to the atomic bomb, but we
hibakusha have always felt
the high possibility of
side effects of the bombing.
Nobody on this planet should
suffer this same tragedy.
Since 2007, I have made
four round-the-world voyages
on Peace Boat, which is sponsored.
It is a Japan-based international NGO.
I learned more about the
situation of the world
during these voyages.
I have visited more than 80 countries,
including ones that are
suffering tragic wars
and the ones that suffer
damage from climate change.
I learned that nuclear weapons
will lead the Earth to destruction.
They are inhumane and should
never be allowed on Earth.
In 2009, Dr. Kathleen Sullivan
and Mr. Robert Croonquist
who are the founders of NY-based NGO
Youth Arts New York's
Hibakusha Stories initiative
kindly invited me and
gave me the opportunity
to share my testimony with
students in high schools
and colleges in New York and Oklahoma.
And since I have made 12 visits
in seven years with their program.
The program has reached
more than 50,000 students and citizens.
During that testimony, I
sometimes use my enamel artworks.
I believe art is a powerful
tool for peace education.
One day, a junior high school
student in New York City
who joined the Hibakusha
Stories program asked me
why I made a friend with Americans
even though I was nearly
killed by the atomic bomb.
My answer was this.
During the war, Japanese
people were taught
to believe that all
Westerners were demons.
In the beginning, it was
very hard to forgive them
for all the suffering caused by the bomb,
but I now believe that hatred
only creates a chain of hatred
and it will eventually lead to killings
and destruction by war.
Humankind needs to make every effort
to cut off this chain of hatred
and instead have love
throughout humanity as a whole.
In 2010, I started to
take part in a campaign
in which we visited local
officials throughout Japan
and collected their signatures
agreeing to support the
anti-nuclear policy.
I also created an art piece
for an anti-nuclear artwork project.
On March 11th, 2011, there
were a series of incidents
at the nuclear power
plant in Fukushima, Japan.
I felt a strong urge
to learn why these things are happening.
In 2012, I joined a project
to visit the areas damaged
by the Chernobyl nuclear power
plant disaster in Ukraine
in 1986 and its neighboring
country, Belarus.
At the Chernobyl plant,
the commission work
had been going on for nearly
30 years, but they said
they might need 40 or 100
more years to finish it.
Our government has not learned
from either the tragedy
on Daigo Fukuryu Maru or
the Chernobyl disaster.
Daigo Fukuryu Maru was
a tuna fishing boat who,
the 23 crew members were
exposed to nuclear fallout
for a nuclear test carried out by the US
in 1954 at Bikini Atoll.
Instead, the Japanese government continues
to produce radioactive substances
which will create even
more victims of radiation.
Doing so, they are also
depriving their own citizens
of food and a place to live.
We do not know when the
disaster in Fukushima will end.
There are many people working tirelessly
for a nuclear-free world.
For instance, ICAN is a global campaign
to promote the abolishment
of nuclear weapons.
On July 7th, 2017, the world
took the essential step
it needed to add peace.
However, none of nuclear
states and their allies,
including Japan, has supported the treaty.
I urge the leaders of
the nuclear weapon states
and other nations not to
dismiss the TPNW idealistic
but to listen to the voice
of people and read the treaty
and think about it again,
and please think about creating
peace, not going to war.
Nuclear weapons do not deter war.
Russia itself is now proving this point.
Last year in 2022, Russian President Putin
started the war in Ukraine,
and suggesting the use of nuclear weapons.
For a survivor who knows
the inhumane tragedy
caused by those weapons,
this is totally unacceptable,
and I feel strong anger and frustrated
that personally could not do anything.
Then I received a video
message from Ms. Tamara
whom I had met 10 years
earlier in my visit to Ukraine.
She strongly asked me, "Ms.
Tanaka, as a bomb survivor,
you have to keep telling the
world about the terrible things
that would happen if
nuclear weapons were used."
Empowered by her message and
with the support of Peace Boat
and Hiroshima-based NGO and Hiroshima,
I gave a talk on Russian
YouTube channel last year.
I hope that hibakushas' voice
has reached Russian people.
In November last year, my
daughter and I were invited
to speak at an international conference
held at Otago University in New Zealand.
I realized how seriously
the nuclear issues
are impacting the Southern Hemisphere
and global South through problems
including nuclear testing
and nuclear waste.
Also, they were developed
and used by the countries
of global North and that
the issues no longer
cannot be solved only by the global North.
We must work together
as a global community
to solve these problems.
During World War II, then
US President Harry Truman
decided to drop atomic bombs
without a second thought.
He said it was necessary in
order to end the war quickly,
but it is believed that the real reason
was to send a message to the USSR.
One of the soldiers who dropped the bombs
from the Enola Gay bomber was Jacob Beser.
You know what?
Clifton Truman, who is a
grandson of Harry Truman,
and Ari Beser, who is a
grandson of Jacob Beser
are both good friends of mine today.
Ari visited me often.
We actually met recently and
spent a good time together.
Both Clifton and Ari are working very hard
toward creating world peace.
If we were still at war,
these good people and I would be enemies.
If we have close friends
from around the world,
we will think twice before starting wars
that just seek personal
prosperity and supremacy.
Empathy is an essential trait
for policymakers and citizens alike.
In the past, Japan caused
the attack on Pearl Harbor
and other vigorous wars on aggression
that left tremendous damage,
especially on countries in Asia.
The Japanese people must reflect on this.
When the atomic bombs were dropped,
people in Northeast Asia
thought, "Now we are freed."
However, the use of nuclear
weapons shocked the world
by creating a different devastation
that changed the concept of war.
When I apologized to my Malaysian friend
for the Japanese military's
atrocious behaviors in the past,
he said, "I don't expect
you to apologize to me now,
but I want you to remember
what happened in the past.
Let's try our best to prevent
another war from happening."
He's a person whose grandfather
was killed by Japanese soldiers.
We as citizens must not
create leaders of a country
that start war for the sake
of territorial expansion
and better economy.
It will lead to an arms race
and eventually to the
use of nuclear weapons,
which will cause horrible devastation
and the end of the world.
We are the crew members of
a ship called Planet Earth.
If the crew members fight each other
for food and a good place
the ship eventually drift
away and be shipwrecked
and none of us will survive.
Now is the time for the
world to help each other
and create peace through diplomacy.
To conclude my story, I
have one request for you,
the young generation.
Please choose the path
to coexist regardless
of your differences including
nationality and race.
If in the future there are
disputes among the nations,
please try to solve them
with words instead of wars.
Once we start wars, we can
only each other as enemies,
not as humans, and we
kill enemies with ease.
Nuclear weapons will lead
the Earth to distraction.
They are inhumane and should
never be allowed on Earth.
I know one day we will live
in a nuclear-free world
and a beautiful blue sky
will continue to shine
above the heads of our future generation.
Thank you for your kind attention.
I will be happy to answer
your questions. Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Attendee] Thank you so much.
Thank you so much to both of
you for coming to speak with us
and thank you so much
for sharing your story.
Yeah, I'm very moved by it,
and it, yeah, it means a lot
that you came to speak
with us, so thank you.
My question is a bit
departing from your story
about the nuclear bomb
itself or the atomic bomb
and more about, I mean, you're
one of the last generation
who will remember and who
was there for the bombing,
but you're also one of the
last generations who remembers
how the city was like before the bombing.
And I'm wondering if there's
anything that you'd like us
to remember or carry about
the city before the bomb,
the city, the people, that
you'd like us to carry with us.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(Reiko Tashiro speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka continues
speaking Japanese)
- So, someone once said that
when they went to Hiroshima
that they saw the Peace Park
in the middle of the city
and they said, "Oh, it's a good thing
that the bomb fell on a park"
without understanding the
reality, which was that in fact
that was the center of the city
where ordinary people made their lives.
And that was of course
completely destroyed and changed
as a result of the dropping of the bomb.
So that person's kind of
misunderstanding was suggestive
of the enormity of what happened.
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
- So the place where the
Peace Memorial now stands
in Hiroshima is precisely
where her kindergarten was.
And so she was supposed to
graduate from the kindergarten
and go to the school.
All of her classmates
who attended that school
died in the bomb.
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
- So it was a beautiful town
and of course in many ways
there were lots of fun
things about the town,
but as a result of all
of her classmates dying,
it also became a place that
she never could go again.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- [Attendee] Thank you so much
for this inspiring speech.
It's very powerful and I...
Like, sometimes it just
almost bring tears to my eyes,
and I really appreciate this opportunity.
So I'm sure an audience really
get your inner strengths.
And that's what I'm thinking,
how you can share with the
younger generation, you know,
under this kind of a circumstance
what make you to stand up
in the middle of this darkness, pain?
What keep you still be
so hopeful and strong?
How you build your resilience
and inner strengths and peace,
that's what I want to know
if you can share with our audience,
especially younger
generation, thank you so much.
(Reiko Tashiro speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka continues
speaking Japanese)
- So after the bomb was dropped
and the city was destroyed,
she as a child remembers
looking up at the sky
and seeing that it was
this beautiful blue sky.
And even though her body was in pain,
she and all of the adults
were of course unable
to look at something like the sky,
but as a child she could look
up and see the sky and think,
"Oh, it's the same sky as yesterday.
If yesterday's sky is here,
then tomorrow's sky will be here.
There will be a tomorrow."
And having lived for 84 years, you know,
she's experienced all sorts of
trials and difficult things,
but she's always felt that she knows
that tomorrow will come,
there'll be a better tomorrow.
So I think that's the...
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Attendee] Like everyone else,
I want to say thank you so
much for sharing your story.
It was really moving.
And my question is that you mentioned
how you didn't tell your
story until you were 70.
And so I wanted to ask, how
did you make that decision?
Why did it take so long?
And then how did you then decide
that you wanted to tell the world?
(Reiko Tashiro speaking in Japanese)
- (speaks Japanese) Good
question. (speaks Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka continues
speaking Japanese)
- So when she was younger,
her feeling was that
even if she talked about what happened,
she wouldn't really be able to have,
no one would be able to understand
who hadn't actually lived through it.
And she also felt that she
didn't want to remember
because all of her classmates had died.
She didn't want to have to think about it.
And she felt also that
some kind of discomfort
towards the people who had died.
But so when she was 70,
the thing that changed
was she went on the Peace
Boat to South America,
to Venezuela.
- Yes, yes.
- And in Venezuela, a mayor in
one of the towns she visited
said, "As somebody who lived through this,
you have an obligation, a
responsibility to talk about it."
And she decided that if
she had a responsibility
to speak about it, then
perhaps the people who died
would be able to forgive
her for speaking about it,
this horrible thing that
had happened to them.
So that became the
catalyst for her decision
to begin speaking openly about it.
And the first time she spoke
was indeed on Venezuelan television.
- Television, teleSUR.
- Tele...
- teleSUR. (speaks Japanese)
- teleSUR apparently is the
TV station in Venezuela.
So that was the first
time she spoke about it.
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
- Peace Boat. (speaks in Japanese)
- So since then she's been on
four trips on the Peace Boat
and visited many different countries
and been able to have the opportunity
to speak about her experiences
all over the world.
(Toshiko Tanaka speaks Japanese)
- [Attendee] I'd like to say thank you
for the work that you do.
It's important, and also it
was delightful to see your art,
which challenges the mind, I
think, to understand it fully.
I didn't know that John
Hersey taught at Yale,
and for those of you who
are two generations younger
than I am, I commend his
book "Hiroshima" to you.
He did the research. He
was a journalist also.
And he did the research
and the book was published,
I think, in '46 or '47,
and it doesn't soft pedal.
It is grizzly at times to
understand what happened.
He also wrote a book
called "A Bell for Adano,"
which won a Pulitzer Prize
and is a happier war story.
So maybe read that after
you read "Hiroshima."
(Reiko Tashiro speaking Japanese)
(Daniel Botsman speaking Japanese)
- John Hersey (speaks Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
(Daniel Botsman speaking Japanese)
- So John Hersey's grandson
actually has visited her
and spent time, they have a connection.
And he actually recently, this
is me adding this, I'm sorry,
but he made a documentary
film a few years ago also
about peace education and the experience
of people like Tanaka-san
so the Hersey connection
is an important one.
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
- So she's very happy to hear
that he's remembered here, too, his work.
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
- [Attendee] Thank you very much.
I found it very, very touching.
I'm curious about how the
disasters that struck Japan,
Hiroshima, Nagasaki, how they're
treated in the classroom.
And what's age appropriate in Japan
for the teaching of this history?
As the American historian
David McCullough said,
"Americans aren't particularly
good at their history."
And I'm not sure how many Americans
are aware of what happened
to Japan, thank you.
(Reiko Tashiro speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka continues
speaking Japanese)
- So for six years after the war,
it was prohibited to
discuss what had happened.
And then in the 1950s there
was gradually the beginnings
of some educational efforts
around the bombings.
But recently there's been yet more change,
and partly as a result
of the war in Ukraine
and Russia's invasion there's
now an effort domestically
in Japan to kind of help to
encourage ordinary people
to open up to the possibility of Japan
becoming a nuclear power and arming.
And so the struggles over these
issues continue within Japan
and have shifted backwards and forwards.
But in the current moment,
various things have happened
that are quite concerning,
including, for example,
one of the most important
post-war comic books
is called "Barefoot Gen,"
and it tells the story
of what happened in Hiroshima
from the perspective of
a boy and his family.
And recently the teaching of that book
has become very controversial.
So it was used in schools in the past,
but recently in Hiroshima they've said
that they're not gonna
use it in schools anymore.
So these things are
domestically in Japan, too,
always being contested and disputed
and things go backwards and forwards.
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
- Whenever there's a change of government,
it seems to shift.
- [Attendee] First of all,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
I feel really lucky to be able to hear it.
I was lucky enough to
visit Hiroshima last month
on a study abroad and saw the
museum there and was saddened
and inspired by it in a way
that I feel I never could be
at any such museum here in the US.
So I'm wondering from
you, what's the best way
that we can share your
story here in the US
with the generations to come?
(Reiko Tashiro speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka continues
speaking Japanese)
- So as a result of Putin's
invasion of Ukraine,
the current moment is
one in which these issues
have become so much more
difficult to discuss.
And there are certainly
people in Japan and elsewhere
who say that the kind of people
who talk about abolishing nuclear weapons
are the kind of people who won't fight
and will just run away, they're cowards.
But from the perspective of hibakusha,
somebody who lived through
the experience of being bombed
with nuclear weapons, her
position is that the true hero
is somebody who doesn't
fight, refuses to kill,
and insists on talking and
talking through the problem
until there's a resolution, so.
- Thank you.
- [Attendee] Hello, thank you very much
for sharing this story.
During the talk, Tanaka-san,
you mentioned that one
of the ways to potentially
avoid future nuclear conflicts
is for empathy between people.
And I just wanted to hear your thoughts on
if you had any ideas on
how you might go about
seeding more empathy in the world,
and particularly following
your efforts on the Peace Boat
and other peace-building activities.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(Reiko Tashiro speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka continues
speaking Japanese)
- So as she mentioned a
little bit in her main speech,
she thinks about the world
as a kind of tiny place
in a huge universe,
but one in which we are
all on board together
as crew members on this kind of ship.
And if the crew members
on a ship start fighting
with each other about who gets the food
or who gets the best
broom, then it's inevitable
that the ship will go off course.
And when that happens, everyone dies.
So from her point of view,
the current moment we're in
is a turning point where
those possibilities
are becoming more and more pronounced.
And so she encourages us all
to think about that reality.
- And the imagination.
- Oh, and use your imaginations
to think about things
in that way so as to prevent
the terrible outcomes
that are likely to occur otherwise.
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
- So she has very high hopes
for all of the brilliant
Yale students out there.
She obviously hasn't met you.
I'm just kidding. (laughs)
No, for all of you,
she has very high hopes
that you will work towards
achieving a better,
more sustainable world,
one in which people do
indeed speak to each other
rather than fighting with each other
when there are problems.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you. (speaks Japanese)
So if there's one more question
anybody has, and then...
- [Attendee] Thank you so much of course
for speaking to us today.
Of course, like, it's important,
you realized that it's important
that you share this story
so that it's not repeated
in the world again.
But what I wanted to ask was that,
how after a life of choosing
to not speak of this
do you balance and take
care of yourself reliving it
so that other people don't have to,
while also not sort of
traumatizing yourself over
and over again and reliving it?
So how do you make that
balance in your head
and take care of yourself while
also speaking on the story
to make sure that other people
don't have to go through
the same thing again?
Thank you.
(Reiko Tashiro speaking Japanese)
- (speaks Japanese) Good
question. (speaks Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka continues
speaking Japanese)
- So she said it's an
extremely good question
and that it is really hard to
talk about these experiences,
but she says recently her
feelings have started to change
and that she's buoyed by the possibility
that by speaking about things,
that it may actually lead
to some positive change
and move the world,
even if it's ever so
slightly in the direction
of abandoning nuclear weapons.
And as I'm sure many of
you know, the G7 meeting
will be taking place in
Hiroshima fairly soon,
and she's really hopeful
that maybe, just maybe,
the leaders at that
conference will be inspired
by their visit to Hiroshima
and take some action
to address this profound problem.
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
- She wants you to know that
there are many people who die
having experienced what
happened in Hiroshima
without ever being able to speak about it.
So she has a friend whose
marriage basically fell apart.
I mean, she wasn't able to get married
because of the fact that
she'd been irradiated
and she remained single
for her entire life.
She's now 85 and she was moved
into a psychiatric home and died there.
And she was never in her
entire life able to speak
about what had happened
to her during the bombing.
So because of that, Tanaka-san
feels as though she needs
to speak so that people
can hear what happened.
- Thank you.
- Please join with me in
thanking Tanaka-san again
for this incredible speech and talk.
(audience applauding)
Oh, I'm sorry, one last question.
- [Attendee] Hi. Thank you
for the very inspiring talk.
So I'm gonna ask a question
on behalf of my daughter.
She would like to know
what you were eating
during the time World War II
because she has a grandma in Tokyo.
Her grandma is originally from Hiroshima,
and she has heard a story from her grandma
saying that she had a hard
time eating during the war
and she just had so many struggles
going through the war period.
So my daughter would like
to know what it was like
living during that time and
eating during that time.
(Reiko Tashiro speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka speaking Japanese)
(Toshiko Tanaka continues
speaking Japanese)
- What a wonderful question.
- Thank you.
- She said that there
really was nothing to eat
during the war, and so
people were eating the grass
from the side of the road.
And because the grass
from the side of the road
was irradiated when the bomb was dropped,
lots of people died as a result
of ingesting the irradiated
weeds on the side of the road.
Then after the war, food
started to arrive from America
and that included things like soybeans
that had been squeezed of their oil,
but even eating that
actually tasted wonderful
after having had no food for so long.
People were truly starving.
So it's a really wonderful question,
and thank you for asking.
Okay, thank you.
Please join with me for our last time
in thanking Tanaka-san for
her wonderful, inspiring talk.
(audience applauding)
(soft instrumental music)